all right oh my god that is crazy oh my
god
my gosh hey uh I forgot to tell you
congratulations on getting the new job
oh thanks man appreciate yes yeah thank
you for inviting me over here to the
game today oh no probably appreciate it
you're my best friend well thanks man
hey you know what you're my best friend
too cool yeah you wrote a song about it
but not gonna sing it or anything cuz
that would be gay be gay all right I'll
give it a shot Wylie you're my best
friend together we can change the world
we've been together through thick and
thin playing ball and talking to girls
Wylie I'm so proud of you you know
you're taking all the my advice wait
stop stop stop stop
what advice oh um it's just a song dude
I mean like an I finish yep and then we
can okay you've done everything I've
asked of you when you never ever
question twice talk about thank you for
doing what I told you to your
achievements are also mine my Padawan
you make your sensei proud living your
life living your life living your life -
my DS I I was the weirdest song I've
ever heard my life you have listened to
your elder and older they never forget
the words I say
don't like your song you wanna boss to
my creation right no no I have shown you
the way except for that you have it just
say when you drag the white wolf guys's
curves through the plains of the caribou
shut up
I have done no like him the rest is up
to my wolf colors all grown up